[Musique]
bonjour françois patriat
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être ce matin
en direct sur rt france alors on a
entendu hier on viens de l'entendre le
chef de l'état qui a esquissé les
grandes lignes d'un assouplissement des
mesures fin de la règle des 10 km lundi
prochain est-ce que c'est pas un peu
prématuré quand on voit que les chiffres
en réanimation n'ont jamais été aussi
haut depuis un an on réanimation c'est
une réelle parce que la réanimation elle
suit de 15 jours environ la phase
maximale de contamination on pense que
nous avons pensé aujourd'hui le premier
ministre l'a dit le chef de l'état aussi
nous pensons que nous avons passé le pic
de contamination il ya quelques jours et
que maintenant
forcément le nombre d'entrées en
réanimation doit diminuer dans les jours
qui viennent et dans le même temps les
gens doivent sortir de réanimation
savait à ce qu'ils nous disaient il ya
trois semaines qu'ils allaient trier
dans les hôpitaux la tribune des
journalistes heureusement et nous
l'avions dit ne s'est pas vérifié on n'a
jamais triché mais aujourd'hui il faut
poursuivre l'effort j'allais dire de la
prudence de sécurité comme l'a dit hier
olivier vers en disant que la sortie se
ferait par paliers qu'elle se ferait
progressivement et non pas brutalement
et qu'elle se ferait territorialement
c'est ce qu'a dit le chef de l'état
permet de dire aux français qu'il y à
une issue à cette nouveau déconfinement
et qui a une issue avec la vaccination à
cette pandémie ce qui peut s'avérer vers
l'été le peu très positive ce message
qu'il faut entendre
soyez prudent ne relevons aucun des
gestes barrières aujourd'hui ne prenons
pas de risques inutiles
mais dans le même temps je pense que
comme le pic est passé aujourd'hui plus
un jour tomber autour j'espère dès des
20000 dans les jours qui viennent
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 30,25 35000
pour retomber à retomber et ensuite qui
arrivait à la réouverture des terrasses
à l'avenir et c'est ce qu'a dit le chef
de l'état idem pour les lieux culturels
avec différentes jauges selon les zones
salle de sport rs courant juin des dates
qui restent néanmoins flou est ce que le
chef de l'état il doit parler en
principe le 5 mai prochain doit-il être
plus clair dans son plan de levée des
restrictions chef de l'état a évoqué
quatre phases entre le début mai et la
fin juin
vous venez de les rappeler à l'instant
par rapport à votre question qui est de
dire le chef de l'état martèle être plus
clair si le chef de l'état s'enferme
dans des dents des dates
j'entends vos confrères j'entends les
commentateurs bien pourquoi s'est-il
enfermés dans des dattes comme hollande
s'était enfermé dans les dates dans la
courbe du chômage
je crois que compte tenu de l'évolution
de la maladie de la sortie de la phase
de confinement que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
le mieux c'est de dire nous allons
ouvrir
nous allons desserrer l'étau nous allons
le faire progressivement nous allons le
faire
territorialement en en fonction des
lieux où aujourd'hui l'évolution de la
maladie se fait se fait de façon moins
grave donc donner des dates précises je
pense que c'est pas possible compte tenu
du fait qu'on ne sait pas si en
réanimation sera 5000 4005 là telle ou
telle date
mais donner une perspective donner un
cadre je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est le
ton juste si l'on vous disait qu'il faut
territorialisée on sait ce que demandent
aussi le finistère où il ya peu de
circulation du virus ou en tout cas peu
de tension dans les hôpitaux
est ce que les français vont s'y
retrouver selon vous s'il ya des des
mesures différentes d'un département à
l'autre
il faut que les français s'y retrouvent
très bien vous souvenez quand il y avait
trois cartes trois cartes superposés
avec les zones très concentré on ferait
c'étaient les mesures étaient très très
forte moyenne et une autre à côté il n'y
avait pas verte orange rouge me souviens
il français sur trouvé très bien il
servait très bien les gens des zones
aujourd'hui l'attention au real plus
faible relevé rich circulent mois ils le
connaissent et ils peuvent le faire
alors j'ai entendu ceux qui viennent des
zones très denses et qui veulent aller
dans les zones dans l'est des zones très
affectés dans des zones où le virus
circule moins se lassent année c'est un
tout petit et ford
j'allais dire le regard et d'attention
pour pouvoir le faire je ne pense pas
que soient les difficultés
je pense que c'est raisonnable on l'a
fait pendant le mois de mars mme
territorialisée les uns on l'a fait
pendant le mois de janvier avec le
couvre-feu les gens ont très bien
compris comment ça fonctionnait
s'accompagne également d'une campagne de
vaccination qui doit s'accélérer si on
veut desserrer l'étau est ce que pour
vous c'est c'est en bonne marche sans
qu'on est toujours très en retard par
rapport par exemple à la grande bretagne
les comparaisons allemagne grande
bretagne italie on peut en faire tous
les jours
la grande-bretagne à 127 milles morts
elle n'a fait qu'une dose de vaccin on
dit pour certains vaccins il faudra
trois doses envoyées qu'elles avancent
ils ont aujourd'hui et je pense que le
camping alcool ils sont en avance sur la
deuxième dose également j'entends bien
et nous avions entendu hier les réponses
qui a eu sur astrazeneca qui a gardé ses
doses pour le royaume uni sans fournir à
l'europe mais dans le même temps
problème astrazeneca feront donc c'est
pas c'est nous sommes le troisième pays
en rythme de vaccination et même parfois
le premier par jour c'est des jours nous
sommes le premier pays
alors dire accélérer la vaccination moi
je vous réponds plus tôt tenons les
engagements qu'a pris le gouvernement et
le chef de l'état aujourd'hui nous
devions faire 10 millions de vaccins à
la mi-avril dames ont fait 12
nous allons passer les 15 ce week-end on
aura plus de quinze je pense début juin
il faut arriver à voir les 20 millions
par an les 20 millions le 15 mai les 30
millions
le 15 juin 32 millions nous espérons
pour les élections régionales et
cantonales et ensuite l'ensemble des
français pour l'été jusqu à présent c c
ce rythme est tenu je sais qu'il ya des
difficultés aujourd'hui avec certains
vaccins et aux récits de le tenir malgré
tout je vois leur est une maxime à sion
plus de 20% de la population de
bourgogne franche comté et vacciner
aujourd'hui c'est le rythme qu'on
s'était donné c'est l'objectif qu'on
s'est donné atteindre il est tenu il
faut le tenir à ce que accéléré c'est
bien joli dire accéléré faut-il encore
qu'il y ait suffisamment doses pour
pouvoir accélérer
or on sait aujourd'hui qu'il n'y en a
pas suffisamment pour accélérer plus et
on va parler de cet hommage de la nation
il ya cette femme policier tué vendredi
par un terroriste dans son commissariat
une cérémonie qui a été très sobre trop
sobre serez vous pas du tout moi je suis
même pas je suis pas de ceux qui tombent
dans le pathos en permanence parce que
je suis je pense que cet événement
dramatique effroyable pour sa famille
pour les habitants ton proto effroyable
on doit le faire dans la dignité
je crois que la sobriété et la dignité
les meilleures marques qu'on puisse
faire de remerciement de gratitude
envers ceux qui disparaissent sous les
coups de boutoir des couteaux des
terroristes après ce qui s'est passé à
rambouillet la présidente de la région
ile de france a fait le lien entre
immigration et terrorisme le
porte-parole du gouvernement lui a à
rejeter ces propos écouter on en parle
après il faut d'abord cessé de nier le
lien entre terrorisme et l'immigration
il y a un lien notamment avec
l'immigration la plus récente
la france a une voix à faire entendre
nous devons organiser un asile à la
frontière tous les migrants demandent
l'asile
on doit pouvoir examiner leur demande
d'asile et les renvoyer
c'est un fait que l'agresseur est issu
de l'immigration qu'il est entré dans
notre pays clandestinement et qu'il a
été régularisée mais ce que je refuserai
toujours c'est de tirer un trait entre
immigration et terrorisme je refuserai
toujours cette idée qui consiste à
dresser les gens les uns contre les
autres et attiser la haine des français
est ce que faire le lien selon vous
c'est attiser la haine comme le dirait
gabriel et al je trouve que c'est un
virage dangereux de madame pécresse qui
nous a pas habitués à ce genre
d'extrémisme de rejoindre pratiquement
aujourd'hui les propos de madame le pen
les propos que j'entends dans la bouche
dans la dans la lecture de la tribune
des officiers en retraite
s'il ya facile je pense que c'est un
raccourci indigne et inutile a dit me
dit il parce qu'il y avait la taille
bien le dire très bien c'est vrai que
que cet assassin est issu d'une
migration il ya beaucoup d' assassinat
en france de gens qui sont pas
l'immigration à côté qui commettent des
actes terribles aussi j'en vois faire le
lien aujourd'hui c'est tombé à la fois
dans dans la facilité dans la xénophobie
à côté je ne partage pas cette analyse
je vois bien qu on est en campagne
électorale que tous les coups sont
permis
mais de grâce mais qui les ont pas un
drame et mac est ce que celui là pour le
transformer en tribune électorale gérald
darmanin qui doit présenter son texte
sur l'antiterrorisme demain en conseil
des ministres que peut-il annoncé plus
finalement pour lutter contre ce
problème on a entendu un ces personnes à
l'hommage de cette femme policier dire
que le gouvernement n'en fait pas assez
que peut-il fable
aujourd'hui j'ai même entendu tout à
l'heure un de vos auditeurs qui disait
que le gouvernement syrien
je pense que là quand on connaît la
réalité des choses mais faut-il encore
l'entendre
le nombre d'attentats qui ont été
déjoués le rôle que joue aujourd'hui le
lancement c'est sur le renseignement
qu'il faut je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya
dans le texte de loi il sera demain en
conseil des ministres ne le connais pas
je pense que c'est sur le renseignement
sur la prévention qui peut le faire le
plus et sur les algorithmes également
donc ça serait plus bien entendu le
recueil des informations
je crois que c'est sur l'information sur
le renseignement
il faut aussi le dire notre si passion
or on a bien vu que ce monsieur incident
n'avait donné aucun signe autour de lui
qu'il a été d ordre manteau cela n'est
pas une excuse du tout mais je vous
rappelle le nombre d'attentats ou de
crime déjoué on le dit pas tous les
jours il faut quand même le rappeler
parfois il ne pas laisser les gens de
dire le gouvernement ne fait rien ne
donne pas les moyens
ce gouvernement se donne les moyens
beaucoup plus que l'on fait les
gouvernements par le passé et j'ai
soutenu d'autres majorités je peux le
dire
l'effort est sans précédent en matière
de sécurité en matière de moyens humains
d'autre part le passé ont supprimé ses
moyens humains n'ont en fait autant
autant pour pour ceux dans ce domaine je
crois qu'il faut plutôt salué l'action
du gouvernement essayait de
l'accompagner plutôt que de mettre en
permanence dans le déni et parfois même
dans le mensonge la lutte contre
l'insécurité on va le voir sera
importante dans le vote de 86% des
sondés et en particulier pour la
république en marche c'est le même
chiffre 86% des mortiers ont la vue ont
été lancés hier contre des forces de
l'ordre à trappes il ya eu des véhicules
de policiers dégradé à rungis comment y
mettre un terme
comment rétablir davantage de sécurité
pour les français alors voyez d'un côté
des mères qui demandent plus de sécurité
plus de renforts de police de l'autre
côté une population qui parle tous les
jours enfin une partie de la population
une partie de la volée la classe
politique qui parle de violences
policières et qui excite la population
contre les policiers à tous a bien
entendu une signe non seulement du
dialogue mais je crois un peu de
réflexion un peu d'éducation on n'est
pas comme ça d'un coup de baguette
magique fin à cette forme de j'allais
dire de zinc contre les policiers qui
existe dans une fraction de la
population et de l'autre côté les maires
qui réclament toujours plus de moyens
après pour certains avoir soutenu leur
diminution
voilà il faut je crois qu'il faut à la
fois non seulement raison garder être
lucide
lucide avoir un petit peu d'abnégation
devant les événements de réagir au plus
fort comme le chef du gouvernement
françois vatry à une dernière question
sur ses généraux à la retraite qui ont
appelé à la sédition dans une tribune
publiée dans le journal valeurs
actuelles voyez d'avoir la réaction de
la ministre des armées qui est
intervenue cinq jours après cette
publication et de la ministre délégué à
l'industrie écouter la tribune
irresponsable publié dans valeurs
actuelles est uniquement signé par des
militaires à la retraite qui n'ont plus
aucune fonction dans nos armées et ne
représentent qu'eux mêmes
je condamne sans réserve cette tribune
d'un quarteron de généraux en
charentaises qui appellent au
soulèvement 60 ans jour pour jour après
le putsch des généraux contre le général
de gaulle
tout ça n'est pas gratuit des généraux
en charentaises a dit agnès pannier une
hache et vous trouvez que le terme et
approprié
je trouve que d'abord j'aime bien la
réaction d'agnès km h et elle a des mots
qui sait avec des maux qui frappent
qu'on peut réveiller l'opinion et en
montrant que ce sont des officiers en
retraite d'ailleurs est il encore à
démontrer qu'il n'y a que des officiers
en retraite je crois qu'une enquête doit
être fait pour savoir s'il n'y a pas des
gens d'actifs qui ont participé en tout
cas de cause cette tribune est il
admissible jour pour jour
elle appelle au soulèvement des généraux
félons à l'époque trouve quelquefois
c'est dangereux et extrêmement dangereux
à la fois pour la république pour la
démocratie qu'est ce que sa crème et que
madame le pen rejoignent aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que ça sera comme le rebelle
est aujourd'hui montre cette
dédiabolisation n'existe pas dites moi
cette rude
écoutez il ya toujours eu une part de
hausse est bien l'armé des forts tendre
et ailleurs qui est tentée pas par par
l'extrême droite parlent par la force
par le bleu c'est nature existe et on a
vu le gl six mois à l'officier de
gendarmerie écrit la même chose dans un
livre il ya le général de villiers qui
écrit son livre aussi honnête cette
tentation de l'armée de rétablir l'ordre
car écouter la france ça n'est pas le
chili ce n'est pas la grèce
nous devons toucher je suis très heureux
de voir que la gauche toute entière
si mobilise aujourd'hui est choqué par
ce parce pas partie de tribune et c'est
peut-être de nature à remettre en place
le front républicain auquel je crois
merci beaucoup françois patriat d'avoir
répondu on dirait que ce matin à nos
questions sur arte france